je pense que tu fais une grosse très
grosse erreur ne fais pas ça tu vas avir
l'air stupide tu V regretter ça va te
donner un look hyper bizarre c'est bon
allez on le fait attends attends une
minute ce truc il te sert à quoi
juste pour mon
corps une tumeur oui moi
ouis c'est complètement
absurde je fume pas je bois pas je
recycle comment vous sentez-vous bien je
crois même que j'ai jamais été aussi
calme depuis hyper longtemps comment
décririez-vous ça comme un état de
stupeur non je me sens juste bien ça va
aller tu es jeunes plein de jeunes ont
vaincu le cancer même des célébrités Tom
green le mec de Dexter lstrong il arrête
pas de la voir je viens vivre ici je
suis ta mère justement tu veux un
macaron oh non ça va
merci il y a du
dedans un médecin fait une ordonnance
pour de la Marana parce que j'y vois
rien la
[Musique]
nuit on aurait pas dû faire ça c'est une
super connerie utiliser ton rasoir à
couille au lie d'aller chez le coiffeur
ouis et en plus je le lave jamais all
salut c'est Adam qu'est-ce qu'il y
a je crois que je pète les plombs ques
sont tes chances il a dit 5050 c'est pas
si mal si tu étais au casino on dirait
que tu es plutôt
verni vous ne pouvez pas changer votre
situation
pouvez changer c'est comment vous
choisissz de
l'affronter tu crois vraiment queill
juste parce que j'ai un
cancerans
j'avaisanc comme ça tu vois ça fait pas
[Musique]
très